When we were weak we told ourselves we were strong. And sometimes-- if we were very weak-- we told ourselves we were very, very strong.
当我们软弱时，我们告诉自己我们很强大。有时——如果我们非常软弱——我们会告诉自己我们非常、非常强大。
I mean, unquestionably, I was by far the most loathed member of my class, I think, you know? Being a pasty, unathletic kid who was weird-looking and probably seemed overly eager, so, you know. And I had friends that would come over on the weekends to play, but then at school, they would ignore me and pretend like they didn't know me.
我的意思是，毫无疑问，我是班上最招人讨厌的学生，我觉得，你知道吗？作为一个脸色苍白、不爱运动、长相怪异且可能显得过于急切的孩子，所以，你知道的。我有朋友周末会过来玩，但在学校里，他们会无视我，装作不认识我。
And so when he was little, Chris Ware spent a lot of time thinking about superpowers. He drew superheroes over and over, trying to get them right. He always wondered where somebody could find a radioactive animal like the one who bit Peter Parker and turned him into the Amazing Spider-Man. Once or twice, he thought he might be developing his own real superpowers.
所以克里斯·韦尔（Chris Ware）小时候花了很多时间思考超级英雄。他一遍又一遍地画超级英雄，试图把他们画好。他总是想，一个人去哪里能找到像咬了彼得·帕克并让他变成神奇蜘蛛侠的那种放射性动物。有一两次，他甚至以为自己可能正在获得真正的超能力。
There was one morning where I was standing under the shower. And of course when you get in, immediately, because you're so cold, the water is extremely hot by contrast, you know? So you have the cold water turned up, and as you stand in there, you get used to it, and you turn the cold water down.
有天早上，我站在淋浴下。当然，当你进去时，因为你太冷了，水温对比显得特别烫，你知道吧？所以你把冷水调大，当你站在那儿，你适应了之后，你又把冷水关小。
And I was in there for a very long time. And I remember turning the cold, and it wouldn't go any farther. And I thought, that's weird. It must be stuck. And I turned it more, and it wouldn't go any farther. And I realized I was standing under completely hot water, but it felt fine to me. It actually felt warm, almost cool. And the longer I stood there, it felt cooler and cooler. And the only explanation I could come up with is that I had developed the ability to withstand extraordinary heat.
我在里面待了很长时间。我记得我拧动冷水开关，但它拧不动了。我想，这真奇怪。一定是卡住了。我又拧了一下，还是不动。我意识到我正站在滚烫的热水中，但我觉得还好。实际上我觉得很暖和，甚至有点凉。我站的时间越长，感觉越凉快。我能想到的唯一解释就是，我获得了一种抵御极端高温的能力。
And of course we'd just run out of hot water. But at that time, I didn't know that that happened. I thought hot water was an endless commodity.
当然，我们只是把热水用完了。但在那时，我不知道发生了什么。我以为热水是无穷无尽的商品。
His first crush was Batgirl. Even now, he says, if he just sees the colors of Batgirl's costume-- just the colors, no image at all, just the colors-- his heart still skips a beat.
他的初恋是蝙蝠少女。他说，即使是现在，如果他只是看到蝙蝠少女服装的颜色——仅仅是颜色，没有任何图像，只是颜色——他的心跳依然会漏掉一拍。
He invented own superhero called the Hurricane, who could shoot blasts of wind from his hands and was drawn with huge, manly muscles. He made a Hurricane costume to wear. Red T-shirt with a black circle with an H on it, a mask that his mom made for him, a yellow cape.
他发明了一个名为“飓风”的超级英雄，能从手中发射狂风，画作里有着巨大、强壮的肌肉。他做了一套飓风装穿上。红色的T恤上面有一个印着字母H的黑色圆圈，妈妈为他做的面具，还有一件黄色的斗篷。
There were a few times where I actually came to school with bits of a superhero costume secreted under my school uniform. I guess, I don't exactly know why. I guess I thought it was like it was going to give me some sense of power or something. But of course then I had gym class, you know? You have to change your clothes, so. I don't know what I was thinking.
有几次，我确实穿着超级英雄服装的碎片藏在校服底下去了学校。我想，我不确定为什么。我想我以为这能给我某种力量感之类的。但当然，我有体育课，你知道吗？你必须换衣服，所以……我不知道我当时在想什么。
There was one time I actually-- this is sort of peripherally superhero-- but I'd actually drawn circuit boards on pieces of paper, like the Bionic Man, the Six Million Dollar Man, and I'd actually taped them on my legs to look like real circuitry exposed, as if I had mechanical legs or something like that. And I guess I vaguely thought that somebody would catch a glimpse of it and think, wow! Look, he's bionic!
有一次我实际上——这属于超级英雄的边缘——我实际上在纸上画了电路板，就像《无敌金刚》或《六百万美元先生》那样，我真的把它们贴在腿上，看起来就像暴露的真实电路，好像我有机械腿之类的。我当时隐约觉得，如果有人瞥见它，会心想：哇！看，他是改造人！
Some of us, we spend a long, long time hoping that we're more than what the world thinks of us. And so of course we're drawn to these stories of these mild-mannered guys who, under their clothes, wear a costume in secret, with powers nobody suspects.
我们有些人，花很长很长的时间希望自己不仅仅是世界眼中那个样子。所以，我们当然会被这些故事吸引，那些平时温文尔雅的人，在衣服底下秘密地穿着制服，拥有没人怀疑的超能力。
And when we get older, it all seems-- well, it all seems ridiculous. It all seems really, really dumb.
当我们年纪大了，这一切看起来……嗯，这一切看起来都很荒谬。这一切看起来真的很傻。
Chris Ware went on to draw cartoons for his living. But these cartoons that he draws now are like novels, about real people. And when a Superman type shows up in one of these cartoons, it's always somebody trying to con kids with a costume and a cape. He is always a disappointment.
克里斯·韦尔后来以画卡通为生。但他现在画的这些卡通就像小说，关于真实的人。当一个超人式的人物出现在这些卡通里时，他总是那种试图用戏服和斗篷欺骗孩子的家伙。他总是让人失望。
It's just more interesting that way. I think he's more like a real dad that way, I guess. And the more I draw him, the fatter he gets, too, and the more bald he gets, I guess. And if you were Superman, too, you know, what do you care what you look like? You wouldn't be all handsome. You'd eat whatever you felt like, you'd take whatever you wanted, and you'd end up looking really terrible after a while, I think. If I was a superhero, I think I would probably-- I mean, who's going to criticize you?
那样反而更有趣。我想他那样更像一个真实的父亲，我想。我画他越多，他变得越胖，也越来越秃，我想。如果你是超人，你知道的，你在意你的长相干什么？你不会一直那么帅。你会想吃什么就吃什么，想拿什么就拿什么，过了一段时间，你看上去会变得非常糟糕，我是这么认为的。如果我是超级英雄，我想我可能会——我的意思是，谁会批评你呢？
Well, today on our radio program, Superpowers, four real life stories about how easy it is to be caught up in the dream of them. Act One, The Invisible Man Vs. Hawkman, the story of one man, two superpowers and one big question, a question, my friend, that we all can face equally.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目《超能力》中，有四个关于人们如何容易陷入超能力梦想的真实故事。第一幕，《隐形人对决鹰侠》，一个男人、两种超能力和一个重大问题的故事，朋友，这个问题我们所有人都同样会面临。
Act Two, Wonder Woman, the story of a kid who decided to take steps to become a superhero, systematic, thorough steps that took her years, well into adulthood.
第二幕，《神奇女侠》，一个决定采取行动成为超级英雄的孩子，系统性、彻底的步骤，花了她几年时间，一直持续到成年。
Act Three, the Green Team of Superhero Boy Millionaires, Beppo, the Amazing Supermonkey from Planet Krypton, and the Man from Sram. In this act, an inquiry into superheroes-- and there are many each year-- that just never caught on.
第三幕，《超级英雄百万富翁绿队》，来自氪星的神奇超级猴子贝波，以及斯兰（Sram）人。这一幕，是对超级英雄的调查——每年都有很多——那些从未流行起来的超级英雄。
Act Four, The Wonder Twins, the story of two 12-year-old boys in Burma, guerrilla fighters, who had entire armies believing that they could stop bullets and summon the dead, and why so many people believe them.
第四幕，《神奇双子》，关于缅甸两个12岁男孩的故事，游击战士，让整支军队相信他们可以挡子弹并召唤死者，以及为什么有那么多人相信他们。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. As the supervillains say, "Silence, miscreant! Our program has begun."
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。正如超级反派所说：“安静，恶棍！我们的节目开始了。”
Act One, Invisible Man Vs. Hawkman.
第一幕，《隐形人对决鹰侠》。
Well, we now present a kind of super-contest for you, beloved super-listener, between two ancient superpowers, two of the superpowers which have fascinated humans since antiquity. And actually, this is kind of a super Rorschach test. John Hodgman has been conducting an unscientific survey, posing for people a very simple choice.
好吧，现在我们要为你，亲爱的超级听众，呈上一场超级竞赛，在两种古老的超能力之间，这两种超能力自古以来就令人类着迷。实际上，这更像是一种超级罗夏墨迹测试。约翰·霍奇曼（John Hodgman）一直在进行一项非科学调查，向人们提出一个非常简单的选择。
Flight versus invisibility? This question is only for you. Whichever you pick, you'll be the only person in the world to have that particular superpower. You can't have both. Which do you choose?
飞行还是隐形？这个问题只为你而设。无论你选择哪一个，你都将成为世界上唯一拥有那种特定超能力的人。你不能两者兼得。你选哪一个？
I started wondering about this a few years ago. I'd bring it up at parties, dinners, wedding receptions. It was more interesting to ask than where people worked or where they went to school, and clearly more fun to answer. Like a magic word, shazam, flight versus invisibility would instantly change an evening's character, opening passionate conversation and debate.
几年前我开始思考这个问题。我会在派对、晚餐、婚礼上提出它。问这个问题比问人们在哪工作或在哪里上学更有趣，而且回答起来显然更有趣。就像一句咒语“沙赞”（shazam），飞行还是隐形会瞬间改变晚宴的氛围，开启热烈的交谈和辩论。
But what surprised me more was how quickly everyone would choose, as though they'd been thinking about it for a long time. Everyone knew exactly which superpower they wanted and what they would do with it. Their plans weren't always flashy or heroic. In fact, they almost never were.
但让我更惊讶的是每个人选择的速度之快，就好像他们已经思考了很久一样。每个人都确切地知道自己想要哪种超能力以及打算用它做什么。他们的计划并不总是华丽或英雄般的。事实上，他们几乎从未那样过。
If I could fly, the first thing I would do is fly into the bar, check out what's going on there, fly back home. I would attach my baby to me and fly to a doctor's appointment at 11:30, fly right back. And then I think I would fly to Atlantic City.
如果我能飞，我做的第一件事就是飞进酒吧，看看里面在发生什么，然后再飞回家。我会把我的宝宝绑在身上，11点半飞去赴医生的约，然后再飞回来。然后我想我会飞去大西洋城。
I would imagine, like, if it got around that I had the power of flight and it was a rare type of thing, I mean, there would definitely be flight groupies. I would imagine. So they're going to be just like, oh, yeah, I just slept with the flying dude. You know? People are just like, oh, score.
我想象，如果大家都知道我有飞行能力，而且这是一种罕见的类型，我的意思是，肯定会有飞行迷。我猜。他们会说，哦，耶，我刚和那个会飞的家伙睡过。你知道吗？人们会觉得，哦，赚到了。
I'd go into Barney's. I'd pick out the cashmere sweaters that I like. I'd go to the dressing room. The woman says, how many items? I'd say, five. I'd go into the dressing room. I'd put those five sweaters on. And I'd summon my powers of invisibility in the dressing room. I'd turn invisible. I'd walk out, leaving her to wonder why there's a tag hanging from the door that says five, and no person inside.
我会走进巴尼斯百货（Barney's）。我会挑出我喜欢的羊绒衫。我会走进更衣室。店员问，几件？我说，五件。我会走进更衣室。我会穿上那五件毛衣。然后我会施展我的隐形能力。我会变隐形。然后走出来，留下她纳闷为什么门上的吊牌写着五件，里面却没有人。
So you'd become a thief pretty quickly.
所以你很快就会变成小偷。
Immediately. Until I had all the sweaters that I wanted, and then I would have to think of other things to do.
立刻。直到我拿到了所有我想要的毛衣，然后我就得考虑做些别的事情。
Typically, this is how it goes. People who turn invisible will sneak into the movies or onto airplanes. People who fly stop taking the bus. Here's one thing that pretty much no one ever says-- I would use my power to fight crime. No one seems to care about crime.
通常情况下，事情就是这样。隐形的人会偷偷溜进电影院或飞机上。会飞的人不再坐公交车。有一件事几乎没人说——我会用我的力量去打击犯罪。似乎没人关心犯罪。
I don't think I would want to spend a lot of time using my power for good. I mean, if I don't have super strength and I'm not invulnerable, then, I mean, it would be very dangerous. If you had to rescue somebody from a burning building or something like that, you might catch on fire.
我不觉得我想花很多时间用我的力量做好事。我的意思是，如果我没有超人的力量，也不是刀枪不入的，那么，我的意思是，那会非常危险。如果你必须从燃烧的建筑物里营救某人或类似的事情，你可能会被烧着。
Just having flight I don't think is necessarily quite enough, because you don't have the super strength.
仅仅有飞行能力我觉得并不完全够，因为你没有超人的力量。
I'd still be weak when I got there, I guess. I don't fight crime now, and people without superpowers do. Sure, in theory, yes. But you know, I'm not a-- I mean, what can I do with this? Either one of those is, you need a whole package. There's not much you can do with any one thing. I'd go to Paris, I suppose.
我想我到了那里还是很弱。我现在也不打击犯罪，而没有超能力的人却在打击。当然，理论上，是的。但你知道，我不是——我的意思是，我能用这个做什么？这两者中的任何一个，你都需要全套装备。单凭其中任何一个你都做不了多少事。我想我会去巴黎吧。
That's not being a superhero.
那不是当超级英雄。
Well, maybe I could be a Going to Paris Man, that sort of a superhero.
好吧，也许我可以成为“去巴黎人”，那种超级英雄。
Going to Paris Man is not a superhero. And I have to say this drove me crazy a little bit. We are, after all, talking about superpowers. Why not take down organized crime, bring hope to the hopeless, swear vengeance on the underworld, if only a little bit?
“去巴黎人”不是超级英雄。我必须说这让我有点抓狂。毕竟，我们谈论的是超能力。为什么不打击有组织犯罪，给绝望的人带去希望，向黑社会宣誓复仇呢，哪怕只是一点点？
I proposed a variety of sample scenarios along these lines, such as, how would you handle a mad genius taking over the Empire State Building, or a group of terrorists hijacking an overseas flight? And what I learned is, some people should simply not be fighting crime.
我提出了各种各样的样本场景，比如，你会如何处理一个占领帝国大厦的疯狂天才，或者一群劫持海外航班的恐怖分子？而我学到的是，有些人根本不应该去打击犯罪。
Well, first thing that occurs to me is, like, I would sneak up behind them very low with a knife that they didn't see and slice their Achilles tendon. Oh, no. I'd somehow shove a sock in their mouth or something like that, and wrap some tape around their mouth, so that they can't yell out. It might not be a sock. It might just be some napkins or something. I can't keep all of this in my head. I'd have to keep a bag full of stuff with me. Knives. Socks. Tape.
嗯，我想到的第一件事是，我会悄悄地从背后低姿态接近他们，用一把他们看不见的刀割断他们的跟腱。哦，不。我会以某种方式往他们嘴里塞一只袜子之类的，然后在他们嘴上缠上胶带，这样他们就喊不出来了。可能不是袜子。可能只是些餐巾纸之类的。我没法把所有这些都记在脑子里。我得随身带着一个装满东西的袋子。刀子。袜子。胶带。
Do you think you'd be tempted to enlist a teenage helper?
你觉得你会忍不住招募一个青少年助手吗？
Um. You know, I think a helper would be good, a helper with a complementary power.
嗯。你知道，我觉得有个助手会很好，一个拥有互补能力的助手。
There's no others, anybody else with superpowers.
没有其他人了，没有其他人有超能力。
Oh, it would just be a teenager hanging around me? No.
哦，那只是一个围着我转的青少年？不。
People who consider invisibility always want to know, do I have to be naked? People who choose flight want to know, how fast? Almost all asked, who would win in a fight, Mr. Invisible or Flying Man?
考虑隐形的人总是想知道，我必须得裸体吗？选择飞行的人想知道，多快？几乎所有人都问，隐形先生和飞行人打架谁会赢？
And so I had to lay down some rules. Invisibility means the power to become transparent at will, including your clothing, but anything you may pick up is visible. Flight means the power to fly at any altitude within the earth's atmosphere at speeds up to 1000 miles per hour.
所以我不得不定下一些规则。隐形意味着能够随意变透明的权力，包括你的衣服，但你捡起的任何东西都是可见的。飞行意味着在地球大气层内以每小时1000英里的速度在任何高度飞行的权力。
But even then, they start looking for loopholes, hidden catches, superpower fine print. They start negotiating their dreams with me.
但即便如此，他们还是开始寻找漏洞、隐藏的陷阱、超能力的细则。他们开始与我商量他们的梦想。
Now, when you're flying, if you're flying at 1000 miles an hour at 100,000 feet, are you comfortable? Do you get very cold?
那么，当你飞行时，如果你在10万英尺高空以每小时1000英里的速度飞行，你舒服吗？你会觉得很冷吗？
Let's say I'm in this room and I'm invisible. And I'm walking around this apartment and I'm invisible. Do I have to be completely quiet, or you guys will, like, hear my footsteps? Because that's a pain in the ass. And also, someone has to let you in.
假设我在这个房间里，我隐形了。我在这个公寓里走来走去，我隐形了。我必须完全安静吗，不然你们会听到我的脚步声？因为那太麻烦了。而且，还得有人让你进去才行。
Can I carry someone? Can somebody go on my back?
我能带人吗？有人能骑在我背上吗？
Can you carry someone on your back now?
你能背人吗？
Little people. Little people, yeah.
小个子。小个子人，可以。
Then you can carry little people on your back.
那你能背着小个子。
Done. Flight it is.
成交。就选飞行。
This is all part of what I call the five stages of choosing your superpower. Sometimes this process occurs in just moments. For example, subject A, a tallish man with glasses, wedged into a cramped barroom corner, begins as they all do, with stage one, gut reaction.
这一切都是我所谓的选择超能力的五个阶段的一部分。有时这个过程只需要几分钟。例如，A先生，一个戴眼镜的高个子男人，挤在酒吧一个狭窄的角落里，像他们所有人一样从第一阶段开始：直觉反应。
Initially, I would think perhaps invisibility.
最初，我可能会认为是隐形。
Next comes stage two, practical consideration.
接下来是第二阶段，实际考虑。
Because you have the ability to walk around work, perhaps show up at one point, and perhaps like go away for a little while, and turn invisible, and then come back and listen to what they say about you. You have the power to spy on your exes. And that would all be enlightening and fun and, in fact, a little bit perverted. And--
因为你有能力在工作中四处走动，也许在某个时间露面，也许离开一会儿，变隐形，然后再回来听听他们是怎么评价你的。你有权窥探你的前任。那会是很有启发性、很有趣，甚至有点变态。而且——
You hear that doubt in his voice? That's the beginning of stage three, philosophical reconsideration.
你听到他声音里的怀疑了吗？那是第三阶段，哲学重估的开始。
That would-- I believe it would immediately turn into a life of complete depression. You wouldn't be able to really share it with anyone, you know? And I know there'd be some problems with, like, the perversion thing.
那会——我相信那会立即变成一种彻底抑郁的生活。你无法真正与任何人分享，你知道吗？我知道关于变态那部分会有一些问题。
Stage four, self-recrimination.
第四阶段，自我谴责。
Invisibility leads you-- leads me, as an invisible person, down a dark path, because you're not going to want to miss out, when you're invisible, on-- you know, no matter how many times you've seen a woman naked in the shower, you're going to want to see it again, because there's always a different woman, right? And there's like a lifetime of that. And that's not acceptable behavior, no matter whether you're invisible or not.
隐形会引导你——引导我，作为一个隐形人，走向一条黑暗的道路，因为你不会想错过，当你隐形的时候——你知道，不管你看了多少次女人在淋浴间裸体，你还是会想再看一次，因为总有不同的女人，对吧？那是一辈子都会做的事。这在任何情况下都是不可接受的行为，不管你是否隐形。
And finally, stage five, acceptance.
最后，第五阶段，接受。
Yeah, I'd have to go with flight.
是的，我不得不选飞行。
So who chooses invisibility and who chooses flight? In my experience, though there are lots of exceptions, men lean towards flying, women to invisibility. And many brood anxiously over their choice, switching from one to the other and back again. And that's because, more than the ability, say, to burst into flame or shoot arrows with uncanny accuracy, flight and invisibility touch a nerve. Actually, they touch two different nerves, speak to very different primal desires and unconscious fears.
那么谁选择隐形，谁选择飞行？根据我的经验，虽然有很多例外，男性倾向于飞行，女性倾向于隐形。许多人焦虑地徘徊在他们的选择之间，从一个换到另一个，再换回来。这是因为，比起比如突然着火或精准射箭的能力，飞行和隐形触动了某种神经。实际上，它们触动了两种不同的神经，诉说着非常不同的原始欲望和潜意识恐惧。
My friend Christine chose invisibility.
我的朋友克里斯汀（Christine）选择了隐形。
One superpower is about something that's obvious, and the other is about something that is hidden. I think it indicates your level of shame.
一种超能力是关于显而易见的，另一种是关于隐藏的。我认为这表明了你的羞耻感程度。
How do you mean?
你是指什么？
A person who chooses to fly has nothing to hide. A person who chooses to be invisible wants clearly to hide themselves.
选择飞行的人没什么可隐藏的。选择隐形的人显然想要隐藏自己。
Do you feel that you want to hide yourself?
你觉得你想隐藏自己吗？
I want to-- I'd like to not-- I'm not going to answer that question.
我想——我不打算回答这个问题。
It all has to do with guile. Wanting to be invisible means that you're a more guileful person. If you want to fly, it means you're guileless. And I think the reason that I'm so conflicted about flying versus invisibility is that I have guile, but I really wish that I didn't.
这一切都与狡诈有关。想要隐形意味着你是一个更狡诈的人。如果你想飞，意味着你没什么城府。我认为我之所以对飞行还是隐形如此矛盾，是因为我有城府，但我真的很希望我没有。
Flight is the hero-- selfless and confident and unashamed. And invisibility, the villain. Almost everyone I talked to called invisibility the sneakier power.
飞行是英雄——无私、自信且不感到羞愧。而隐形，是反派。我交谈过的几乎每个人都称隐形是更狡诈的能力。
Flying is for people who want to let it all hang out. Invisibility is for fearful, crouching masturbators.
飞行是给那些想要展现一切的人准备的。隐形是给那些胆怯的、畏缩的自慰者准备的。
First of all, I think that a lot of people are going to tell you that they would choose flight, and I think they're lying to you. I think they're saying that because they're trying to sound all mythic and heroic, because the better angels of our nature would tell us that the real thing that we should strive for is flight, and that that's noble and all that kind of stuff.
首先，我觉得很多人会告诉你他们会选择飞行，而我觉得他们在对你撒谎。我觉得他们那么说是为了听起来更神话、更英雄，因为我们天性中更好的一面会告诉我们，我们真正应该追求的是飞行，那是高贵的，诸如此类。
But I think actually, if everybody were being perfectly honest with you, they would tell you the truth, which is that they all want to be invisible so that they can shoplift, get into movies for free, go to exotic places on airplanes without paying for airline tickets, and watch celebrities have sex.
但我认为实际上，如果每个人都对你完全诚实，他们会告诉你真相，那就是他们都想隐形，这样他们就可以顺手牵羊、免费进电影院、不买机票就去异国他乡、看名人们做爱。
Anyone faced with this choice, in their heart of hearts, will choose invisibility.
任何面对这个选择的人，在内心深处，都会选择隐形。
Yes. Or they have this sort of inflated, heroic, mythical concept of themselves, and that, in fact, they're not really giving it very much practical thought.
是的。或者他们有一种膨胀的、英雄的、神话般的自我概念，而事实上，他们并没有进行多少实际的思考。
In the end, it's not a question of what kind of person flies and what kind of person fades. We all do both. Perhaps that's why, when I put the choice to myself, I'm hopelessly, completely stuck. At the heart of this decision, the question I really don't want to face, is this. who do you want to be, the person you hope to be, or the person you fear you actually are? Don't rush into it. Think it over. Which would you choose?
最后，这不是什么样的人飞行、什么样的人隐形的问题。我们两者都会做。也许这就是为什么当我把自己放在这个选择面前时，我彻底地陷入了困境。在这个决定的核心，那个我真正不想面对的问题是：你想成为什么样的人？是你希望成为的人，还是你恐惧自己实际上是的那个人？别急着做决定。好好想想。你会选哪一个？
John Hodgman in New York City.
纽约市的约翰·霍奇曼。
[MUSIC - "THAT MAN" BY PEGGY LEE]
[音乐 - 佩吉·李的《那个男人》]
Act Two, Wonder Woman.
第二幕，《神奇女侠》。
OK, what are the ways to create a superhero? Gamma rays. Space alien abduction. Prison experiment or a NASA flight gone awry.
好吧，创造超级英雄的方法有哪些？伽马射线。外星人绑架。监狱实验或NASA飞行出错。
And then there's the idea of a list. Is it possible that a to-do list is powerful enough to achieve this incredible result? Kelly McEvers met somebody who tried.
还有列清单这个想法。待办事项清单真的强大到足以实现如此惊人的结果吗？凯利·麦克伊弗斯（Kelly McEvers）遇见了一个尝试过的人。
We met in a bar in Flagstaff, Arizona. I'd just moved back from Cambodia and I was going out for one of my first beers back in the States. Not long into the first one, I notice this Amazon of a woman with huge blond and red-streaked hair and frosty lips, wearing a short red tank dress and at least 50 bracelets. She's six feet tall and showing a lot of leg. People at the bar swivel their heads to watch her every move.
我们在亚利桑那州弗拉格斯塔夫的一家酒吧见面。我刚从柬埔寨搬回来，正要去喝回国后的第一杯啤酒。刚开始没多久，我就注意到这个长得像亚马逊女战士的女人，留着巨大的金色和红色挑染的头发，涂着霜色嘴唇，戴着至少50个手镯。她身高六英尺，露出一大截腿。酒吧里的人都转头注视着她的一举一动。
She stands next to me to order a drink, and in this throaty voice says, "What are those?" pointing to my cigarettes. I tell her they're Cambodian. Her eyes light up and she shoots out a long, tan arm, and points at a table in the corner. She orders me there. Before I can say no, I'm following her to my seat.
她站在我旁边点了一杯酒，用那低沉的声音说：“那是些什么？”指向我的香烟。我告诉她是柬埔寨的。她的眼睛亮了起来，伸出一只长长的、晒成古铜色的手臂，指向角落里的一张桌子。她命令我去那儿。还没来得及说不，我就跟在她身后到了座位上。
She tells me she's an international private investigator, a bounty hunter, and a bail bonds enforcer, and that her name is Zora. I sit there for hours listening to her. Within a week, she takes me to Las Vegas. We drive there in her red Mustang. As always, there's a Colt .380 under the driver's seat and a .45 Megastar in the trunk.
她告诉我她是国际私家侦探、赏金猎人和保释金执行官，她叫佐拉（Zora）。我在那里坐了几个小时听她说话。一周之内，她带我去了拉斯维加斯。我们开着她的红色野马车去。像往常一样，驾驶座下藏着一把Colt .380手枪，后备箱里有一把.45 Megastar手枪。
In Vegas, we skip the casinos and head straight for the male strip clubs, where Zora drops at least $200 on lap dances from buff guys with names like Roman. Her getup is the same as before-- teeth, hair, jewelry, and the ubiquitous tank dress, which, I realize, is the best way to show off her tattoos.
在拉斯维加斯，我们避开了赌场，直奔男性脱衣舞俱乐部，佐拉在那里给像罗曼（Roman）这样肌肉发达的家伙撒了至少200美元买私人舞。她的行头和以前一样——牙齿、头发、首饰，还有那件无处不在的背心裙，我意识到那是展示她纹身的最好方式。
One is this big circle with blue and white swirls in it, kind of like a bowling ball, on her left shoulder. Every guy she meets asks her about it, and when they hear her answer, they sometimes propose marriage. Turns out the tattoo is a magic globe she holds in her dreams. And in these dreams, it gives her superpowers.
其中一个纹身是一个带着蓝色和白色漩涡的大圆圈，有点像保龄球，在她左肩上。每个她见到的人都会问起它，当听到她的回答时，他们有时会求婚。原来这个纹身是她在梦中持有的一个魔法地球仪。在这些梦里，它赋予了她超能力。
Ever since I remember, I've had the dreams. And they're very vivid. But it varies. It usually involves fighting, sometimes with guns, sometimes with superhero powers. Lightning from my fists and all that. And I usually have super strength, and I can fly, and I have all those things.
自从我记事起，我就一直做这些梦。它们非常生动。但内容各异。通常涉及战斗，有时用枪，有时用超能力。拳头发射闪电之类的。我通常有超人的力量，我能飞，拥有所有那些能力。
And it's my most common set of dreams. And it varies. Sometimes it's medieval, sometimes it's futuristic, sometimes it's present day, sometimes it's like a guerrilla war in Latin America.
这是我最常做的梦。内容不定。有时是中世纪的，有时是未来的，有时是当代的，有时像是在拉丁美洲的游击战。
Can you describe that Zora to me, the Zora in dreams?
你能向我描述一下那个佐拉吗，梦里的那个佐拉？
Very powerful athletically, but beyond the rules of nature that this world allows. It's a six foot five and long, like almost impossibly long silver hair. This sort of otherworldly quality to her, where her voice did not sound normal. It sounded, like, almost musical.
身体非常强大，但超出了这个世界允许的自然规则。身高六英尺五英寸，留着几乎不可思议的长长的银色头发。她有一种超凡脱俗的气质，她的声音听起来不正常。听起来几乎像音乐。
And it became something that I aspired to be. I aspired to be this sort of superhero, this sort of person who would fight for a cause. That was my motivation in life. Ever since I was 10 or 11, I decided that that was my goal.
这成了我渴望成为的样子。我渴望成为这种超级英雄，这种会为事业而战的人。这是我人生的动力。从10或11岁起，我就决定了那是我的目标。
Zora took the dreams seriously. So seriously that at the age of 12, she sat down and composed a list of some 30 skills she needed to learn if she wanted to become as close to a superhero as any mortal could be. She even gave herself a deadline-- to master these skills by the time she was 23.
佐拉严肃地对待这些梦。甚至在12岁时，她就坐下来写了一份清单，列出了30项她需要学习的技能，如果她想尽可能接近超级英雄，就得掌握这些。她甚至给了自己一个截止日期——在23岁之前掌握这些技能。
I don't know what's in these.
我不知道这里面有什么。
Zora pulls out the old spiral notebook that was her diary at the age of 13 and turns to the inside back cover.
佐拉拿出了那本她13岁时的旧螺旋装订日记本，翻到封底内侧。
There's the list.
清单就在那儿。
Wow. Why don't you go ahead and read it.
哇。你为什么不读读看呢。
OK. The list included martial arts, electronics, chemistry, metaphysics, hang gliding, helicopter and airplane flying, parachuting, mountain climbing, survival--
好的。清单包括武术、电子学、化学、形而上学、悬挂式滑翔、直升机和飞机驾驶、跳伞、登山、生存——
Throughout her teens and 20s, each time she started a new diary, she would update the list and write it in the back of the book, each one with the same format, each one titled "The List."
在她的整个青春期和20多岁时，每次她开始写一本新的日记，她都会更新清单并写在书的背面，每一本格式都一样，每一本都标题为“清单”。
Weaponry, rafting, scuba diving, herbology-- yes, I, studied that-- CPR, first aid and mountain emergency kind of medicine.
武器、漂流、水肺潜水、草药学——是的，我学过那个——心肺复苏术、急救和登山应急医学。
The list also includes bodybuilding, archery, demolitions, and explosives. She wanted to learn how to hunt animals and track men.
清单还包括健美、射箭、爆破和炸药。她想学习如何狩猎动物和追踪人类。
Major physical conditioning.
主要的体能训练。
And the most incredible thing about all of this is that Zora accomplished nearly every item on the list.
这一切最不可思议的事情是，佐拉完成了清单上的几乎每一项。
Throwing stars and compound bows and throwing knives and-- yes, it was a very interesting pastime.
飞镖、复合弓、飞刀以及——是的，这是一种非常有趣的消遣。
To keep up with the goals set by the list, she sped through school. Starting in the seventh grade, she began completing entire school years during the summer term and finished high school by the time she was 15. She got her BA at 18, a master's at 20, and completed the coursework for a PhD in Geopolitics by the time she was 21. She wanted to live like Indiana Jones, spending half her time in the classroom and half her time saving the world in the jungles of Peru.
为了跟上清单设定的目标，她飞快地完成了学业。从七年级开始，她就开始在暑期修完整个学年，在15岁时完成了高中学业。她在18岁获得文学学士学位，20岁获得硕士学位，并在21岁时完成了地缘政治学的博士课程。她想活得像印第安纳·琼斯（Indiana Jones），一半时间在课堂，一半时间在秘鲁丛林中拯救世界。
Item number four-- camel, elephant riding. Evasive driving and stunts.
第四项——骑骆驼、骑大象。应急驾驶和特技。
When you're a kid, you have these romantic visions of what you'll be when you grow up. But how many people are so diligent they commit their dreams to paper and make it their life's work to achieve them? How many keep a list, amending it, adding to it, ticking things off as they go along, well into their adult lives?
当你是个孩子时，你会对长大后成为什么样的人有着浪漫的憧憬。但有多少人勤奋到把梦想付诸纸上，并将其作为一生的事业去实现呢？有多少人坚持写清单，修订它，增加它，随着年龄增长，一直勾选清单上的事项？
After finishing the course work for her PhD, Zora decided to quit school, disappointed at the lack of cliff-hanging adventure in her doctoral program. And since superheroes who live in the real world need jobs, she decided to seek employment at the only place that would allow her to put all the skills from the list to use. Zora wanted to become an agent in the CIA.
在完成博士课程后，佐拉决定退学，因为对博士项目中缺乏那种扣人心弦的冒险感到失望。既然生活在现实世界的超级英雄需要工作，她决定在唯一一个能让她用上清单上所有技能的地方寻求就业。佐拉想成为中情局（CIA）的特工。
And so began a rigorous application process. Interviews, psych exams, a three-day lie detector test.
于是申请流程开始了。面试，心理测试，三天的测谎仪测试。
After that, then they sent investigators out to interview me, interview my neighbors, interview ex-boyfriends, interview friends, ex-friends, former colleagues, people I worked with, people I used to work with.
在那之后，他们派调查员去采访我，采访我的邻居，采访前男友，采访朋友、前朋友、以前的同事、曾经一起工作过的人。
They threw a question out in the middle of an interview. So what would you do in this situation? If you were driving down the road, and you had one of your native agents with you, someone who's going to give you some information, and you were in a third world country somewhere, and you were driving a car, and you accidentally ran into a dog, and people have been out playing in the street, children in the street, they see their dog get killed, and they get upset, and they rush towards the car, what do you do in that situation? You don't want to draw attention to the person who's with you.
他们在面试中抛出一个问题。那么在这种情况下你会怎么做？如果你正开车走在路上，车上有你的当地特工，一个要给你提供信息的人，你正在某个第三世界国家，你在开车，你不小心撞到了一条狗，人们一直在街上玩，街上有孩子，他们看到狗被杀死了，他们变得非常心烦意乱，冲向车子，在这种情况下你会怎么做？你不想引起和你一起的那个人注意。
So what I said was that I would tell my agent to get down lower in the car, and I would get out of the car and draw the attention to myself, and try to appease them in some way, either by giving money, more likely. And that was an acceptable answer. That was a good answer to them.
所以我说，我会告诉我的特工把身体压低，我会下车把注意力吸引到自己身上，并试图以某种方式安抚他们，最可能是给钱。那是一个可接受的答案。对他们来说，那是一个好答案。
At the time, when I was going through the process, it felt like everything was coming together. And I had not felt so much joy probably ever.
当时，当我经历这个过程时，感觉一切都要实现了。我可能从未有过如此多的快乐。
Did you tell them about your dreams?
你告诉他们你的梦了吗？
Absolutely not. I would tell them that I had a sense that I could combine the whole street smarts intellectual, the education with the sort of adventure personality. And I was actually told that I had the perfect personality for it, and that I would do really well. It was like the fruition of my life, that it was going to be the step into the next-- you know, where I would be using all that list in preparation for the next phase, which would be to actually put it into practice.
绝对没有。我会告诉他们，我有种感觉，我可以把那种街头智慧、知识、教育和那种冒险性格结合起来。我实际上被告知，我有完美的性格，我会做得很好。这就像是我人生的果实，那是迈向下一阶段的一步——你知道，我将在那里使用所有的清单来为下一阶段做准备，也就是付诸实践。
About eight months into the interviews, Zora got a letter saying she'd been rejected. She appealed over the next year and a half, partly to find out why they'd turned her down, but the best they could do was to tell her to try again in a few more years. In the end, the CIA wouldn't take her, and they wouldn't even tell her why.
在面试大约八个月后，佐拉收到一封信说她被拒绝了。她在接下来的一年半里不断申诉，部分是为了找出他们拒绝她的原因，但他们能做的最好的事情就是叫她几年后再试。最终，中情局不要她，甚至不告诉她原因。
Probably it took me more like two years to recover. I was a basket case. I was just down. You know? I would have to work. I couldn't concentrate. Sort of slump down, staring at the wall. I put my whole life into examination, all the years of preparation.
大概花了两年时间我才恢复过来。我简直崩溃了。我只是很沮丧。你知道吗？我得工作。我无法集中注意力。就那样消沉地坐着，盯着墙看。我把整个人生都投入到了审查中，投入了所有的准备工作。
Most of us give up our dreams of superhero adventure when we're adolescents. Zora was only getting to it at the age of 27. Here she knew how to fly a helicopter and survive in the wilderness, but for what?
我们大多数人在青春期就放弃了超级英雄冒险的梦想。佐拉在27岁时才刚刚触及它。在这里，她知道如何驾驶直升机和在荒野中生存，但为了什么？
She devoted a lot of time to thinking about why she might have been rejected by the CIA. Maybe it was all those months she spent with right wing militia groups, doing her doctoral research. Maybe she shouldn't have told the CIA how she ended up in a clandestine IRA club one night while on vacation in Ireland. Maybe the CIA didn't like the fact that her father, a professor at the University of Minnesota, is an outspoken Serbian nationalist. Or maybe it was simply her own fault, that she couldn't turn herself into a superhero.
她花了很多时间思考为什么会被中情局拒绝。也许是因为她花了好几个月和右翼民兵组织在一起，做她的博士研究。也许她不该告诉中情局她某天在爱尔兰度假时是如何溜进一个秘密爱尔兰共和军（IRA）俱乐部的。也许中情局不喜欢她父亲——明尼苏达大学的一位教授——是一位直言不讳的塞尔维亚民族主义者。又或者这纯粹是她自己的错，她无法把自己变成一个超级英雄。
I had violated the agreement of the list, violated the agreement that I made with myself, that I had not become what the archetype was, that I'd become something lacking. The point being that my mythology should have guided me better, and it felt like such a final thing.
我违反了清单的约定，违反了我和自己达成的协议，我没有成为那个原型，我成为了一个有所缺失的人。重点是，我的神话本该引导我得更好，这感觉真是最终的结局。
So Zora remade herself. She had been virtually isolated from other people since she was 15, when she started actively pursuing the goals on the list. Her parents were happy she was so busy, because she had no time for boys.
于是佐拉重塑了自己。她从15岁开始积极追求清单上的目标时，就几乎与世隔绝。她的父母很高兴她这么忙，因为她没有时间结交男孩。
But now she started working for a woman private investigator. One day when she went to court, she wore her first pair of pantyhose, because she was told it would help her look more feminine. Soon after, she was schooled in the sheer power of lipstick, a short skirt, and a supermodel runway walk to control the minds of others.
但现在她开始为一位女私家侦探工作。有一天她去法庭时，她穿上了第一双连裤袜，因为有人告诉她这会让她看起来更女性化。不久之后，她学会了口红、短裙和超模猫步的力量，以控制他人的思维。
These days she works for an international private investigation agency that handles these kinds of cases.
如今，她在一家处理此类案件的国际私家侦探社工作。
Child abduction, retrieval of custody, reverse stings, occult and ritualistic crimes. Those tend to be really interesting. I like working on those. Anti-terrorism, kidnap protection and return, counterintelligence.
儿童绑架、监护权追回、反向陷阱、邪教和仪式犯罪。那些往往非常有趣。我喜欢从事这些。反恐、绑架保护和营救、反间谍。
She's happy doing this work. In a typical case, Zora's agency sent her on a mission to Mexico to do what's known as a reverse scam. The agency was hired by the family of a young woman who'd recently traveled there and fallen in love with the man she planned to marry after knowing him for only 10 days. The family suspected some sort of con.
她对这份工作很满意。在一个典型的案件中，佐拉的机构派她去墨西哥执行所谓的反向诈骗任务。该机构受雇于一名年轻女子的家人，她最近去那里旅游，认识那个男人才10天就打算和他结婚。家人怀疑有什么骗局。
Zora contacted him, pretending she was looking for a girlfriend who used to work with him in the travel industry. She took a photo of a classmate with her to begin the scam.
佐拉联系了他，假装她在找一个曾在旅游业和他一起工作的朋友。她带了一张同学的照片去开始这个骗局。
I sort of played the distressed American student going to a Spanish school. And he invited me on a couple of dates, and asked me to come back for the bullfight.
我扮演了一个正在西班牙学校学习的、心烦意乱的美国学生。他邀请我约会了几次，并请我回来参加斗牛比赛。
What did you wear?
你穿了什么？
I wore like a little itty-bitty skirt and a little tank top. I made it seem like I had plenty of money, and that interested him. He kind of perked up at that.
我穿了像一条很小的短裙和一件小背心。我表现得好像我有很多钱，这引起了他的兴趣。他对此有点兴奋。
He never mentioned, the whole time that I ever spent any time with him, he never mentioned that there was ever a woman. I found him to be pretty emotionally open and a very romantic guy. But I honestly felt that he probably was not in love with her, that he was taking this as an opportunity to live in the United States. And that was the report I gave.
在我和他在一起的整个时间里，他从来没提过有别的女人。我觉得他是个感情开放、非常浪漫的家伙。但我诚实地感觉，他可能并不爱她，他只是把这当作一个移居美国的机会。那是我给出的报告。
Before Zora set out for Mexico, I rode with her to the airport. We were late and hurrying through the terminal, just 10 minutes to spare, when she did the strangest thing. She sat down in a chair, far from the gate, and wouldn't move. I told her she was going to miss her flight, but she didn't budge.
在佐拉出发去墨西哥之前，我载她去机场。我们迟到了，匆忙穿过候机楼，只剩下10分钟，这时她做了一件最奇怪的事。她坐在椅子上，离登机口很远，不动了。我告诉她她要错过航班了，但她不为所动。
I sat down next to her. She said she was scared. About the case? About which disguise she might wear? About being found out? No, she said. She said she was afraid that when she got to Mexico, people wouldn't like her.
我在她旁边坐下。她说她害怕。关于案子？关于她可能穿哪种伪装？关于被发现？不，她说。她说她害怕当她到达墨西哥时，人们不会喜欢她。
The next time I was at her house, I hadn't noticed before, but I realized her bookshelf was packed with advice on how to build confidence. Titles like Princessa: Machiavelli For Women. Books like that aren't really so far from the idea of keeping a list, having an ongoing plan for self-improvement, believing that if you just put something on paper and stick to it, you can change.
下一次我在她家时，我之前没注意到，但我发现她的书架上摆满了如何建立自信的建议。书名比如《公主：女性的马基雅维利主义》。像这样的书与保留一份清单、有一个持续的自我完善计划、相信只要把某事写在纸上并坚持下去，你就能改变的想法并没有那么远。
Zora still has her list. But while the old list was all about being perfect and saving the world, the new list is very different.
佐拉还有她的清单。但旧的清单都是关于完美和拯救世界的，而新的清单却截然不同。
I need to learn how to play tennis and golf. And my new list is windsurfing, tennis, golf. I need to develop some kind of talent. Like, I need to learn how to sing properly, or to do some kind of comedy or sketches, acting. I need to learn how to act. Oh, I need to learn how to sing like Billie Holiday.
我需要学习如何打网球和高尔夫。我的新清单是帆板、网球、高尔夫。我需要发展某种天赋。比如，我需要学习如何正确地唱歌，或者做某种喜剧或素描，表演。我需要学习如何表演。哦，我需要学习如何像比莉·哈乐黛（Billie Holiday）那样唱歌。
She doesn't take the list so seriously these days. There are no deadlines. She puts things on the list and later decides not to do them. It's not a grand mission anymore. Now it's just a list.
这些天她没那么认真地对待清单了。没有截止日期。她把事情列在清单上，后来又决定不做了。这不再是一个伟大的使命。现在这只是一个清单。
Kelly McEvers.
凯利·麦克伊弗斯。
[MUSIC - "GOLDFINGER" BY DAVID SEDARIS]
[音乐 - 大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）的《金手指》]
Billie Holiday imitator David Sedaris. Coming up, exactly what Superman knows that Jigsaw Man doesn't, in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
比莉·哈乐黛模仿者大卫·塞达里斯。接下来，超人究竟知道些什么而拼图人（Jigsaw Man）不知道，稍后继续，来自国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Superpowers, and how easy it is to get caught up in the dream of superpowers.
这是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为你带来各种不同种类的故事。今天的节目，《超能力》，以及陷入超能力梦想是多么容易。
We've arrived at Act Three. Act Three, The Green Team of Superhero Boy Millionaires, the Amazing Supermonkey from Planet Krypton, and the Man from Sram.
我们来到了第三幕。第三幕，《超级英雄百万富翁绿队》，来自氪星的神奇超级猴子贝波，以及斯兰人。
My friends, they come in waves, 100 a year or more, whole armies of them. I'm talking about new superheroes created by the comic book companies. It is rare for any of them to last more than a few issues.
我的朋友们，它们像潮水一样涌来，一年100个甚至更多，整支军队。我说的是漫画公司创造的新超级英雄。很少有能持续超过几期的。
The website Gone and Forgotten is, as far as we can tell, the authoritative archive of these failed supersouls. The guy who runs the site, under the title "Your Humble Editor," is Jonathan Morris.
网站“Gone and Forgotten”据我们所知，是这些失败超级灵魂的权威档案。经营该网站的家伙，头衔是“你谦卑的编辑”，是乔纳森·莫里斯（Jonathan Morris）。
He says that the few great superheroes have some common sense things going for them. One, they have powers that make intuitive sense. Two, they have a reason for fighting crime. Three, their stories have a human touch to them. You can relate to them.
他说，少数伟大的超级英雄有一些共同的感官优势。第一，他们的能力直观合理。第二，他们有打击犯罪的理由。第三，他们的故事有人情味。你能与他们产生共鸣。
He agreed to come into the studio with a stack of some of the comics that do not quite measure up to those super-standards.
他同意带一摞那些不太符合超标准的漫画进演播室。
I'm trying to find a very good one. I've brought a ton of comics with me. Let's see. We've got Captain Marvel, who is one of the characters featured on the website. His amazing power is that he can split, by which we mean his limbs fall off and then flail around. Hopefully, I imagine--
我正试图找一个非常好的。我带了大量漫画。让我们看看。我们有惊奇队长（Captain Marvel），网站上的角色之一。他惊人的力量是能“分裂”，意思是他的四肢会掉下来然后乱挥。我希望，我想象中——
What?
什么？
--beating up the criminal. I'm not kidding. He says "Split!" His arms, legs, and head fall off, and he screams, "Yow! I popped apart!" And with the word "Zam," he returns to normal, and he's flying into action.
——打败犯罪分子。我没开玩笑。他说“分裂！”他的手臂、腿和头掉下来，他尖叫着：“哟！我掉零件了！”随着一声“赞”，他恢复正常，然后飞进行动中。
I don't even know why. That is one of the most disturbing things I've ever heard.
我甚至不知道为什么。那是我听过的最令人不安的事情之一。
This company had a number of characters who shared their names with pre-existing characters. They had a Plastic Man who appeared in this very issue, in fact, but he was nothing like the famous Plastic Man.
这家公司有几个角色的名字与现有的角色重名。他们有个塑料人（Plastic Man），实际上出现在这一期，但他和著名的塑料人完全不一样。
Which was always an embarrassment to him. He'd be ordering online, or he'd--
这总是让他感到尴尬。他会在线购物，或者他会——
Gets his mail all the time.
老是收到他的邮件。
Exactly. He'd make a reservation at a restaurant, and then he'd show up, and they're like, oh, we thought you were the other Plastic Man.
正是。他会预订餐厅，然后他到了那儿，他们会说，哦，我们以为你是那个塑料人。
And there's even a point where he hears people yell "Plastic Man" on the street, and he's long past the point where he's thinking, maybe they mean me. No. He knows they mean the guy in the red.
甚至有一次他在街上听到人们喊“塑料人”，他早就过了那种心想“也许他们是指我”的阶段了。不。他知道他们是指穿红色衣服的那个家伙。
I did bring all the Prezes with me.
我确实带了所有的Prez漫画。
Prez?
Prez？
Prez. The first teen president of the United States. A rather earnest young man named Prez Rickard becomes-- and with a name like that, how could he not? He becomes the first teenage president of the United States.
Prez。美国第一位青少年总统。一个相当认真的年轻人，名叫Prez Rickard——有着那样的名字，他怎么可能不是？他成为了美国第一位青少年总统。
This is the issue right before he has to fight vampires, too, which was not a responsibility I was aware the president had. But apparently, it's rather important.
这是他不得不去对抗吸血鬼之前的那一期，我不知道总统还有这种责任。但显然，这相当重要。
Now, what is his superpower? Like, what kind of president does he make?
那么，他的超能力是什么？比如，他是个什么样的总统？
Well, he kind of fits in that Doc Savage-Batman mold, where he's mostly a very well-trained human. He's taught by his-- I hate to say this-- his stalwart Indian companion how to develop the all-important Indian tracking skills. And thanks to his Indian companion Eagle Free's menagerie of animals, he learns several animal skills, helping teach Prez Rickard to be fast as an antelope, swing like a monkey, fight like a bear, I guess.
嗯，他有点符合Doc Savage-Batman那种模式，他主要是一个训练有素的人类。他被他的——我不想这么说——他被他忠实的印第安伙伴教导如何开发极其重要的印第安追踪技巧。多亏了他的印第安伙伴Eagle Free的动物集结，他学到了几种动物技能，帮助教会Prez Rickard像羚羊一样快，像猴子一样摆动，像熊一样打架，我想。
You know, I've always thought that the United States presidency would be so much more effective if the president had the powers to communicate and control the animals.
你知道，我一直认为如果总统拥有沟通和控制动物的能力，美国总统职位会有效率得多。
Well, if there's one thing that Prez proves, it's that there's nothing that the president couldn't solve with two fists, an Indian companion, and a small army of birds and elephants.
好吧，如果说Prez证明了一件事，那就是没有什么事是总统不能用双拳、一个印第安伙伴和一小队鸟和象来解决的。
If you were to explain to people the characteristics of a bad comic book superhero--?
如果你要向人们解释糟糕的漫画超级英雄的特征——？
There are obviously a lot of ways you can screw up. One of the ways is to just overdo it and cram the elements of the character down the readers' throats. One of the characters was Bee-Man and everything about him was bees. His full name was Barry E. Eames. He was attacked by mutant bees which were sent to earth by space alien bee people. And he himself became a mutant bee person who had bee powers, and lived in a hive, and ate honey, and stole gold because gold looked like honey. And he could sting you.
显然有很多方法可以搞砸。其中一种方法就是过度用力，把角色的元素硬塞给读者。其中一个角色是蜜蜂侠（Bee-Man），关于他的一切都是蜜蜂。他的全名是Barry E. Eames。他被一群变异蜜蜂袭击，那是太空外星蜜蜂人送往地球的。他自己也变成了一个变异蜜蜂人，拥有蜜蜂能力，住在一个蜂巢里，吃蜂蜜，偷金子，因为金子看起来像蜂蜜。而且他能蜇人。
There was nothing bee-related this man refused to do. If you meet somebody at a bar, you start talking to him, and you realize, he only has one interest in life-- that's exactly what Bee-Man was. Everything would have gotten back to bees. You start talking about what you watched on television last. He'll say, you know, I saw an interesting show on bees.
没有什么是这个男人拒绝做的，只要和蜜蜂有关。如果你在酒吧遇到一个人，你开始和他说话，然后你意识到，他生命中只有一个兴趣——这就是蜜蜂侠的样子。一切都会回到蜜蜂身上。你开始谈论你上次在电视上看了什么。他会说，你知道，我看了一个有趣的关于蜜蜂的节目。
You know how there's certain stores, like in a neighborhood, and no matter what business moves in, they always fail? There's just one after another after another? Are there certain powers that when people try to give them to people, it's just inevitably a formula for failure?
你知道在街区里有些特定的店，无论什么生意搬进去，总是失败吗？就一个接一个的？是否有一些能力，当人们试图赋予它们时，注定是一个失败的公式？
There's one power that never survives on its own, and they always end up enhancing it. And that would be shrinking.
有一种能力是无法单独生存的，他们总是以增强它而告终。那就是缩小。
Now, why would that be? Because that conforms to the rule of, there's something intuitive about that that anybody can understand. You get small.
现在，为什么会那样？因为它符合那个原则：有一个直观的东西是任何人都能理解的。你变小了。
There is something intuitive about that. But then you also realize that, all right, you're small. Now I can take you.
关于那一点确实很直观。但随后你也意识到，好吧，你变小了。现在我可以抓住你了。
And usually the power that they'll add is what kind of thing? Like, what kind of things will they add to the little guys?
通常他们会增加的能力是什么？比如，他们会在小个子身上增加什么样的东西？
Well, usually the one they get is, you get to keep your full human strength. They like to give them something relating to being small. Ant-Man has the ability to control ants. And again, as I say it, I realize that's probably not much better.
嗯，通常他们得到的是，你可以保持完全的人类力量。他们喜欢赋予他们一些与变小有关的东西。蚁人有控制蚂蚁的能力。再重申一次，我意识到这可能好不到哪里去。
Well, I was going to say, like, yeah.
嗯，我正想说，比如，是的。
He's as strong as a guy, and here are some ants.
他和一个男人一样强壮，这儿有一些蚂蚁。
He would just invade the picnics of supervillains.
他只会入侵超级反派的野餐。
Do certain comic superheroes come out of particular moments in the nation's history?
某些超级英雄是否出自国家历史的特定时刻？
Positively. That's another thing that really works against a character, is when they're tied in too tightly to a fad, or tied in too tightly to something that is identifying an era. There's a character created in the '70s, but who was supposed to be a retro character from the '50s, name of 3D-Man, to help hook up on the 3D movies that were a craze in the '50s. Terrible. Flat character. Nothing going on.
确实。这是另一件真正不利于角色的事，那就是当他们被太紧密地绑定在某种风潮，或者被太紧密地绑定在定义时代的某种事物上时。有一个角色是在70年代创造的，但被设定为一个来自50年代的复古角色，名字叫3D侠（3D-Man），为了搭上50年代3D电影风潮的顺风车。太糟了。扁平的角色。什么都没有。
And when you say 3D-Man, what was his power?
当你提到3D侠时，他的超能力是什么？
He had a magical pair of glasses and had the strength of three men. And that's it. He was as strong as three people, as fast as three people, whatever that means. Probably three times faster than a human being. They always describe it as something as "so much as three men," but I don't see how he can be three times as-- or have "the agility of three men." There's just three guys who are agile. It doesn't make any sense. I have a little trouble with 3D-Man.
他有一副神奇的眼镜，拥有三个人的力量。就这样。他拥有三个人的力量，三个人的速度，不管这意味着什么。可能是比人类快三倍。他们总是把它描述为“相当于三个男人”，但我看不出他怎么能三倍地……或者拥有“三个人的敏捷性”。只是三个敏捷的家伙而已。那根本说不通。我对3D侠有点困惑。
Part of the problem with just naming off the superheroes or going through their powers is that, on the face value, there's not a superhero who doesn't seem silly, because you have to get to a point where the man's wearing a costume and he's driving around fighting crime.
单单列举超级英雄或经历他们的能力的一部分问题在于，表面上来看，没有一个超级英雄看起来不傻，因为你必须达到一个地步，即男人穿着戏服，开车去打击犯罪。
Then where does the line come where they rise above that? Do you have a theory on this, about what makes a good one and a bad one?
那么他们超越那一点的界限在哪里呢？你对此有什么理论吗，关于什么造就了好的和坏的？
I have sort of a half-formed theory. I know that one of the things that really helps a superpower get over with the audience, get over with the readers, is if it's something they can apply to their normal lives, perhaps by way of fantasy. And that's, I think, why super strength, super speed, invulnerability, or just general toughness are often so common. If you can get on the court with it, get that super accuracy, and get a slam dunk from midcourt, and really just school over somebody, then that's probably a superpower you want.
我有一个半成型的理论。我知道，真正有助于超能力吸引受众、吸引读者的因素之一是，如果这是他们可以通过幻想应用到正常生活中的东西。我认为这就是为什么超力量、超速度、刀枪不入或一般强壮如此常见。如果你能带着它上球场，从半场投篮得分，真正地在某人面前表现，那么那很可能就是你想要的超能力。
But when you start getting into powers like one character who had magnetic eyes of superpower, which is a little too esoteric to even understand.
但当你开始进入某些能力，比如一个角色拥有“超能力磁铁眼”，这太深奥了，甚至让人无法理解。
Yeah. I don't even understand it. What does it mean? "Magnetic eyes of superpower"?
是的。我甚至不懂。那意味着什么？“超能力磁铁眼”？
Yeah. In his first appearance, he announced that he had magnetic eyes of superpower. They would illustrate little beams coming out of his eyes, making metal things shoot right at them, which would be terrible in a room full of forks.
是的。在他第一次登场时，他宣布他有超能力磁铁眼。他们会画出小光束从他眼睛里射出，使金属物体直接向他们飞去，那在满是叉子的房间里会很糟糕。
Jonathan Morris, who brought a few of his 15,000 comics into the studio. Search the internet for Gone and Forgotten and you'll find his site.
乔纳森·莫里斯，带了他15000本漫画中的几本到演播室。在网上搜索“Gone and Forgotten”，你会找到他的网站。
[MUSIC - "SIGNAL IN SKY" BY THE APPLES IN STEREO]
[音乐 - THE APPLES IN STEREO的《天空中的信号》]
IRA GLASS: Act Four, The Wonder Twins.
艾拉·格拉斯：第四幕，《神奇双子》。
You may have read or heard something of this story, how in a civil war in Burma, the Karen people's guerrilla army, God's Army, had these two twin boys with them starting when the boys were just nine years old, Johnny and Luther Htoo. Finally, they came out of the jungle, smoking cigars and looking much younger than their 12 or 13 years. But for a while, many people believed that they had superpowers.
你可能读到或听到过这个故事，在缅甸内战中，克伦族（Karen）游击军，“上帝军”（God's Army），在双胞胎男孩约翰尼和卢瑟·赫图（Johnny and Luther Htoo）仅仅9岁时就开始带着他们。最终，他们走出了丛林，抽着雪茄，看起来比他们12或13岁的年纪要年轻得多。但有一段时间，许多人相信他们拥有超能力。
Jason Bleibtreu reported on them in Burma. He says there was actually a legend that preceded their appearance.
杰森·布雷布特鲁（Jason Bleibtreu）在缅甸报道了他们。他说实际上在他们出现之前就有一个传说。
The legend of the twins had to do with Burmese mythology. And the mythology was, when the Karen people, which are an ethnic minority, when things are really tough for them, twins would appear. The twins would have magical powers and they could save them from bad, from evil things.
双胞胎的传说与缅甸神话有关。神话是，当克伦人——一个少数民族——当处境非常艰难时，双胞胎就会出现。双胞胎会拥有魔法力量，他们可以从坏事、邪恶中拯救他们。
And what superpowers did people believe they had, Johnny and Luther?
人们相信约翰尼和卢瑟拥有什么超能力？
The twins at one time claimed, and also their followers claimed, that the twins were able to command ghost armies. Each twin had 200,000 to 300,000 soldiers that they could command. And when the fighting got tough, they could call on these ghosts and the ghosts would come to support them. Other mystical powers were things such as bullets would bounce off of them, or if they were struck by shrapnel from a landmine, it would bounce off of them.
双胞胎曾经声称，他们的追随者也声称，双胞胎能够指挥幽灵军队。每个双胞胎有20万到30万士兵可以指挥。当战斗变得艰难时，他们可以召唤这些鬼魂，鬼魂会来支持他们。其他神秘力量包括诸如子弹会从他们身上反弹，或者如果他们被地雷的弹片击中，它也会反弹。
Jason, in the course of your reporting, did you meet people who claimed to have witnessed the twins using any of these powers?
杰森，在你的报道过程中，你遇到过声称目睹过双胞胎使用这些能力的人吗？
Oh yes. Certainly. I met several people, many people. They told the stories about, during meditation, the kids would be meditating with the twins, and all of a sudden, they'd open their eyes, and there would be an old man sitting there. And it would be the body of an old man, but inside it would be one of the twins.
哦，是的。当然。我遇到了好几个人，很多人。他们讲了故事，在冥想期间，孩子们会和双胞胎一起冥想，突然间，他们睁开眼睛，会有一个老人坐在那儿。那会是老人的身体，但里面是其中一个双胞胎。
Another one was, they're going into battle. So one of the twins took his weapon, his M-16, pointed it to the ground, and he fired 20 rounds. Later that day, his troops came back and said, we killed 20 soldiers. He says, yes, we killed 20 soldiers because I fired 20 rounds into the ground.
另一个故事是，他们要投入战斗。其中一个双胞胎拿起他的武器，M-16，指向地面，开了20发子弹。那天晚些时候，他的部队回来并说，我们杀死了20名士兵。他说，是的，我们杀了20名士兵因为我往地里开了20枪。
So I understand that, in the course of your reporting, you visited with the twins, is it twice? While they were still out fighting?
我知道在你的报道过程中，你拜访过双胞胎，是两次对吗？当他们还在战斗时？
Yes. I visited with God's Army several times.
是的。我几次拜访了“上帝军”。
And when you would ask the twins directly, you know, do you have powers, let me see the powers, would they answer directly? Would they say, yes, I have these powers? Or would they talk around it, you know?
当你直接问双胞胎，你知道，你有能力吗，让我看看这些能力，他们会直接回答吗？他们会说，是的，我有这些力量吗？还是他们会拐弯抹角，你知道？
They would talk around it, and I would push and push and push, and I would get answers like, yes, I have magical powers. But those powers only come out in desperate situations, like when we're in battle. I just can't bring up the magical powers just to show you.
他们会拐弯抹角，我不断地逼问，我会得到像这样的回答：“是的，我有魔法能力。但那些能力只会在绝望的情况下出现，比如我们在战斗中时。我不能为了给你展示就把魔法能力随便拿出来。”
What was their affect? How would they respond? Were they embarrassed? What would they do?
他们的举止怎么样？他们会怎么回应？他们尴尬吗？他们会做什么？
I'd push with questions, and then they would get irritated. They would get angry. Several times Luther lifted up a machete and would threaten me with it. I could hear him through the translator. I would get the translation. He would say stuff like, "This guy's bothering us, isn't he? Isn't he really bothering us now?" I don't think I like this guy."
我逼问他们，然后他们会感到恼火。他们会生气。有好几次卢瑟举起一把砍刀威胁我。我可以通过翻译听到他。翻译会告诉我。他会说这样的话：“这家伙在烦我们，不是吗？他现在真的在烦我们，对吧？我不喜欢这家伙。”
And so what were they like?
那么他们是什么样的人？
Luther was quite shy, fidgety. He seemed to lack much attention and strived to get attention. Johnny is more confident and outgoing. Both of them were treated like kings. Both of them rarely walked on the ground. Most of the time, they were carried on someone's shoulders.
卢瑟相当害羞、局促不安。他似乎很缺乏关注，并且努力想要获得关注。约翰尼更自信、外向。他们俩都被像国王一样对待。他们很少走在地上。大多数时候，他们被背在别人的肩膀上。
It's interesting. So then, in their own little world, they were sort of superheroes.
真有趣。所以，在他们自己的小世界里，他们算是超级英雄。
Oh, certainly. One of the kids would bark out, "I want to smoke," and they would run out and they would grab the cigarette and light it. He would want a lighter, they would run and grab a lighter. He'd want something to eat, they'd run off and get him something. He wanted to be lifted up, they would lift him up. He wanted down, they would put him down. They would bark out commands, and most of the commands would be adhered to.
哦，当然。其中一个孩子喊道：“我要抽烟。”他们就会跑出去，抓起香烟并点燃。他要打火机，他们就会跑过去拿打火机。他要吃的，他们就会跑去拿东西给他。他要被背起来，他们就会背他。他要下来，他们就会放下他。他们发出命令，大多数命令都会被执行。
How do you think it affected them? Did you get a sense of that?
你认为这如何影响了他们？你有感觉吗？
Certainly Luther, he wanted attention. He was a boy who needed to hug. He was a boy who didn't have his mother around, didn't have his father around. There were no mother figures in the camp. They didn't want women there. And it just seemed like he wanted some affection. He would go from soldier's lap to soldier's lap, and he would just sit in the lap of the soldier. Or he would come up behind the soldier and he'd quickly put his hands around him and give him a little hug . (INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: At the point when they surrendered to Thai troops, they wrote a letter to their mom, and the letter said, "In Burma, we were very hungry, but now we have food. The Thai army is looking after us. It is a nice life here. We want to stay with you. We miss you, Mommy."
卢瑟当然需要关注。他是一个需要拥抱的男孩。他是一个没有母亲在身边，没有父亲在身边的男孩。营地里没有女性角色。他们不想让女人在那里。这看起来就像他想要一些关爱。他会从士兵的膝盖换到另一个士兵的膝盖，就那样坐在士兵的膝盖上。或者他会走到士兵身后，迅速用手环住他并给一个小的拥抱。（采访者）艾拉·格拉斯：当他们向泰国军队投降时，他们写了一封信给妈妈，信里写道：“在缅甸，我们非常饥饿，但现在我们有食物了。泰国军队在照顾我们。这里生活很美好。我们想和你在一起。我们想你，妈妈。”
Yeah. They didn't enjoy being in the mountains, on the run. It was a tough life. They weren't well-nourished. And yeah, they missed their mother and they missed their father.
是的。他们不喜欢在山里东躲西藏。那是一段艰难的生活。他们没有得到很好的营养。是的，他们想念他们的母亲和父亲。
Do you think that the way the twins came to power in this group, that a part of them believed that they might have magical powers?
你认为双胞胎在这个群体中掌权的方式，是否有一部分是他们自己相信可能拥有魔法能力？
It's very difficult to say. They believed that they were special. They were treated special. I don't think that Johnny or Luther believed that they had magical powers.
这很难说。他们相信自己是特别的。他们被当作特别对待。我不认为约翰尼或卢瑟相信他们有魔法能力。
I don't know. If I were young child, and I were told that there was this legend that I and my twin were going to come and that we would have these special powers, a part of me probably would believe, well, I don't have the power right now, but maybe, in some circumstances, I could.
我不知道。如果我是一个小孩子，被告知有这个传说，我和我的双胞胎会降临并且拥有这些特殊能力，我可能有一部分会相信，好吧，我现在没有这种力量，但在某种情况下，我可能有。
Yes, you have a point there. And it's quite possible. But I don't think that they believed that they ever did something magical. Nor do I think that they were psychotic. I think that they were part of a con.
是的，你有道理。这很有可能。但我不认为他们相信自己曾经做过什么魔法的事。我也不认为他们有精神病。我认为他们是骗局的一部分。
When you say a con, you mean a con by whom, perpetrated on whom?
当你说是骗局时，你是指谁的骗局，针对谁？
God's Army, this group of the Karens, were down and out. They needed some type of miracle. They needed people to believe them. I believe that they created Johnny and Luther, claiming that they were gods, so that they could con people into fighting for them and they could intimidate their enemies.
“上帝军”，这群克伦人，走投无路了。他们需要某种奇迹。他们需要人们相信他们。我相信他们创造了约翰尼和卢瑟，声称他们是神，这样他们就可以骗人来为他们战斗，并恐吓他们的敌人。
It's interesting. First they try to win through politics, and then through arms, and then when arms fail, they have to go straight to myth.
这很有趣。首先他们试图通过政治赢得胜利，然后通过武装，而当武装失败时，他们不得不直接诉诸神话。
Yes, it's true. They were desperate. They don't have anything left. They don't have that many fighters. They don't have resources. They don't have many weapons. And it's a desperate act by a group of desperate people.
是的，这是事实。他们绝望了。他们什么都不剩了。他们没有那么多的战士。他们没有资源。他们没有多少武器。这是绝望的人采取的绝望行动。
Did it work for a while?
它奏效了一阵子吗？
Yes, it worked for a while. And then the Burmese forces were intimidated by them and scared of them, and believed this. So yes. And they gathered a lot of support amongst the people in the mountains.
是的，它奏效了一阵子。然后缅甸军队被他们震慑住，惧怕他们，相信了这一点。所以是的。他们在山里的人民中聚集了很多支持。
Jason Bleibtreu, speaking to us from Bangkok, Thailand.
杰森·布雷布特鲁，从泰国曼谷为我们报道。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Blue Chevigny, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Elizabeth Meister runs our website with production help from Todd Bachmann, Annie Baxter, and Jane Golombisky. Musical help today from Mr. John Connors.
今天的节目由亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我本人与布鲁·谢维尼（Blue Chevigny）、乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）和斯塔利·凯恩（Starlee Kine）制作。高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。特约编辑保罗·托（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）负责运营我们的网站，Todd Bachmann、Annie Baxter和Jane Golombisky协助制作。今天的音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯（John Connors）先生。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to get a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. Look us up in the book or call 312-948-4680. Or you know you can get tapes from our website, where perhaps in an economically unsound decision, we also make it possible for you to listen to our programs for free at www.thisamericanlife.org.
如果你想获得这期或我们任何节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ。在书中查阅我们或拨打312-948-4680。或者你知道你可以从我们的网站获取磁带，在那里，或许是一个经济上不合理的决定，我们也让你能够免费收听我们的节目：www.thisamericanlife.org。
There you can also find, this week, a cartoon by Chris Ware, who I interviewed at the beginning of the program today, a cartoon about superheroes and their power over us. It's really just beautiful. Chris, by the way, is the author of Jimmy Corrigan: The Smartest Kid on Earth.
在那里你还可以找到，本周，由克里斯·韦尔（Chris Ware）绘制的一幅卡通画，我在节目开头采访了他，关于超级英雄以及他们对我们的影响的卡通。真的很美。克里斯，顺便说一下，是《吉米·科里根：地球上最聪明的孩子》的作者。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《此美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who told me back when he hired me--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他当初雇我时对我这么说——
You have the ability to walk around work, show up at one point, and perhaps, like, go away for a little while, and turn invisible, and then come back and listen to what they say about you.
你有能力在工作中四处走动，在某个时间露面，也许离开一会儿，变隐形，然后再回来听听他们是怎么评价你的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《此美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。